This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是由真人录制。2%。当旁边有自动扶梯时，只有这么一小部分人会选择走楼梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在这个光怪陆离的现代世界中培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“2%”。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，对当时的我和我来说，那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方收听Look Back At It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《学得艰难》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。这并不意味着你有这种能力。并不意味着你需要去听在iha radio app、apple podcast或任何你
get your podcast and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology this week we're discussing the psychology of failure um this was inspired by a sex in the city episode i've been obsessed with that show recently. I don't know why. Maybe it's like moving to a new city, a big city that's really got me into it, but Carrie did a, did an, um, what is it called? An article, I guess, on failure and I was like, this is great inspiration from the podcast, or for the podcast. So, from now on, all podcast episodes will make direct references to sex in the city episodes. But that aside, I think the reason why it kind of stuck with me is because we're
获取播客的地方收听“Learn the Hard Way”并欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理学意味着什么。本周我们讨论的是失败的心理学，嗯，这灵感来自于一集《欲望城市》，我最近对那个节目着迷了。我不知道为什么。也许就像搬到一个新城市，一个真正让我着迷的大城市，但凯瑞做了一个，做了一个，叫什么来着？一篇关于失败的文章，我想，这真是播客的绝佳灵感，或者说是为播客提供的灵感。所以，从现在开始，所有的播客节目都会直接引用《欲望城市》中的剧集。但抛开这个不谈，我想它之所以一直留在我脑海里，是因为我们
were all inevitably going to fail in our 20s, probably multiple times, whether at work or uni in relationships, dealing with finances or leaps of faith where we fall short. Even just like perceiving failure and things that aren't really failures, they're just mistakes or things we wish we'd done differently. So I think it's important to kind of get our head around it. And for me at the moment. I think there's just been a few things in the past six months where I've felt like a sense of failure for some reason. Perhaps it's unjustified. But yeah, most of these episodes I kind of just do because it's something I'm thinking about a lot at the moment. So if you're in the same boat, hopefully you get something out of this episode. But before we dive in, I just want to say thank
在二十多岁时难免都会失败，可能还不止一次，无论是在工作、大学、处理财务关系方面，还是在放手一搏却没能成功的时候。甚至只是把一些并不是真正失败的事情视为失败，它们只是犯了错误，或者是我们希望自己能换一种方式去做的事情。所以我认为把心态调整好是很重要的。对我目前来说。我想过去六个月里有几件事不知为何让我感到了一种失败感。也许这种感觉毫无根据。但对，我做大多数这些节目只是因为这是我目前经常思考的事情。所以如果你也处于同样的境地，希望你能从这一期节目中有所收获。但在我们深入探讨之前，我只是想说
you for all the support and love. My two recent episodes have gotten, the one I did, the two that I did with Claudia. I have been getting heaps of messages from people who have been tuning in. And honestly, it makes me so happy. It makes my day. I like heard this quote the other day and it says, when you put something out there in the world, 10% of people are going to hate it. 80% of people are going to be indifferent and 10% of people are going to love it. So for all of those who do love it, thank you so much for reading, for reaching out to me and making that known. And if you do feel called to do so, please consider leaving a review on either Spotify and Apple Podcasts. It would be, obviously, massively appreciated. It helps the podcast grow, helps my ego a little bit.
感谢大家所有的支持和厚爱。我最近的两集节目得到了大家的喜爱，一集是我做的，另一集我和克劳迪娅一起做的。我收到了大量来自收听者的信息。说实话，这让我太开心了。这让我的一整天都充满了好心情。我前几天听到这样一句话：当你把某样东西公之于众时，10%的人会讨厌它，80%的人会无动于衷，10%的人会喜欢它。所以对于所有喜欢它的人，非常感谢你们的阅读、联系我并表达你们的支持。如果你也愿意这么做，请考虑在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上留个评论。这显然会让我们非常感激，这有助于播客的发展，也稍微满足了一下我的虚荣心。
And then as always, thanks for tuning in to this episode. Failure is such a messy, messy concept in our younger years when small mistakes can feel so life-altering and permanent. But the more mistakes we make, the more I guess we learn that they aren't the end of the world, the consequences don't last forever, and the more we kind of learn in general. So this episode, we're going to talk about why failure is important in this decade of our lives, how it affects our behavior and our self-concept and how to overcome negative feelings or perhaps a fear of failure. How to move on to let's go. I think failure is not just, confined to our professional or academic lives as we so often think they are, you can fail at
像往常一样，感谢收听本节目。在我们年轻的时候，失败是一个非常纷繁复杂的概念，那时一些小小的错误就会让人觉得翻天覆地且无法挽回。但我们犯的错误越多，我想我们就越能明白它们并不是世界末日，后果也不会永远持续下去，总的来说我们学到的东西也就越多。所以这一期节目，我们将探讨为什么失败在我们人生的这十年里如此重要，它如何影响我们的行为和自我概念，以及如何克服负面情绪或对失败的恐惧。如何继续前行，冲吧。我认为失败并不仅仅局限于我们常以为的职业或学术生涯，你可能会在
so many things in your 20s and chances are it's going to be the first of many more times we experience that feeling. Like I said, I do think we often think about failure in terms of constructed, you know, almost artificial settings where you either pass or you fail. There's no gray area and the decision is kind of made for you, you know, failing an exam, failing a driving assessment, failing to get a job that you really wanted. But in this episode, I want to kind of push out a little bit further and talk about a sense of failing at something more intangible and the sense that you can fail in any area of your life, not just academic, professional or an examination sense.
二十多岁的许多事情上失败，而且很有可能是我们经历这种感觉的众多开始中的第一次。就像我说的，我确实认为我们经常从构建好的、几乎是人为设定的情境来考虑失败，在这些情境中要么及格要么不及格。没有灰色地带，结果已经为你决定好了，比如考试不及格，驾考没通过，没能得到一份你梦寐以求的工作。但在这期节目中，我想把范围稍微扩大一点，谈谈在更无形的事物上遭遇失败的感觉，以及你可能会在生活的任何领域失败的感觉，而不仅仅是在学术、职业或考试的意义上。
So, an example. I was talking to a dear friend the other day about her long-term relationship that had ended just recently. And they had been together for two years and as we were kind of debriefing and going through the timeline of events, I asked her if she had told her parents yet. And she said no, that she hadn't. And when I asked her why, she said she was embarrassed. She didn't want them to think that she had failed at her relationship. And I remember having a similar feeling after someone I was dating. After I ended things, I felt like such a failure.
举个例子。前几天我和一位亲密的朋友聊天，聊到她最近刚结束的长期恋爱关系。他们已经在一起两年了，在我们复盘并梳理事件时间线的时候，我问她是否已经把这事告诉父母了。她说没有，还没说。当我问她为什么时，她说她觉得很尴尬。她不想让父母觉得她在感情上失败了。我记得在我交往过的一个人之后，也有过类似的感受。在我结束那段关系后，我觉得自己是个彻头彻尾的失败者。
A failure for having invested time in this person, a failure for not having seen the red flags, seeing the signs, for having told my friends and my family that I really like this guy, only for, you know, things to come to an end in a way that was like not amazingly satisfactory. And in the aftermath,
为在这个人身上投入了时间而感到失败，为没有看出红线、没有看到征兆而感到失败，为曾对朋友和家人说我真的很喜欢这个家伙，结果事情却以一种不那么令人满意的方式结束而感到失败。而在那之后，
I feel like I felt like I couldn't trust myself or my judgment anymore. And that's such a critical feature of the sense of failing, the self-loving that comes afterwards. So we are going to metaphorically kind of fail at so many things in our 20s. We're going to fail at keeping friendships fail at feeling successful enough. Sometimes the stakes are really high. But for most people, I would say, this decade of our 20s is a time when failures won't mean the end of the world or life as you know it. I'm guessing you don't have kids. You don't have big financial responsibilities, meaning you have a bit more of a safety net.
我觉得我再也无法信任自己或自己的判断力了。这是失败感的一个极其关键的特征，也就是随之而来的自我折磨。所以我们在二十多岁时，会在许多事情上遭遇隐喻意义上的失败。我们会在维持友谊上失败，在觉得自己不够成功上失败。有时赌注确实很大。但对大多数人来说，我想说，二十多岁这十年是一个失败并不意味着世界末日或你所熟悉的生活终结的时期。我猜你还没有孩子。你没有巨大的经济责任，这意味着你拥有更多的安全网。
You can always pick up your life and move. You know, nothing's really holding you down to the environment that you've made those failures in. So it's the perfect time to kind of teach yourself to pick yourself up and learn the lessons that that moment and that experience was intended to teach you. And the chances are you'll fail again and again and again in different ways until one day you'll just start failing at something different. So what does psychology have to say about the impact of failure on our minds, our behavior, our self-concept?
你随时可以重新开始生活并搬家。你知道，没有什么真正能把你束缚在那些导致你失败的环境中。所以，这是教导自己重新振作起来，并吸取那一刻和那段经历本意要教给你的教训的绝佳时机。而且很有可能你会以不同的方式一次又一次地失败，直到有一天你开始在不同的事情上失败。那么，心理学对失败如何影响我们的思维、行为和自我概念有什么看法呢？
How can we adopt, I guess, a more positive relationship with making mistakes and failing in this formative decade of our lives? So failure, it hits us where it hurts for a number of reason, and it starts really early on in childhood, as so many reactions and patterns often do. Failure and fault are virtually inseparable in so many households, in so many organisations and cultures. Every child learns at some point that admitting failure also means taking blame.
在我们人生的这个形成期，我们该如何培养与犯错和失败的更积极的关系呢？所以失败，由于种种原因直击我们的痛处，而且就像许多反应和模式一样，它在童年时期就开始了。在许多家庭、许多组织和文化中，失败和过错实际上是不可分割的。每个孩子在某个时刻都会学到，承认失败同时也意味着承担责备。
Perhaps you're scolded or you're told to go to bed, you know, you let the dog outside by accident or you fail a test and you receive some form of punishment for your behaviour. and your failure, which leads to a negative internal reaction and a bad feeling that you inherently want to avoid. So after repeated positive or negative punishment, so either the removal of a good thing or the introduction of a bad thing to influence our behavior by an outside force, maybe a parent or a teacher, soon we don't even need those figures in our lives to make us feel bad and to get us to avoid mistakes.
也许你被训斥了，或者被告知去上床睡觉，你知道的，你不小心把狗放出了门外，或者考试不及格，你的行为和失败受到某种形式的惩罚，这导致了内部的负面反应以及一种你天生就想避免的不良体验。因此，在经历了一系列积极或消极的惩罚之后——也就是通过外界力量（比如父母或老师）移除好东西或引入坏东西来影响我们的行为——很快我们甚至不需要生活中的这些人物来让我们感觉糟糕并让我们避免犯错。
We have internalized that feeling. Now we have a fear of failing. We stop ourselves from failing because we've had enough experiences to anticipate what will happen if we do. We've been conditioned to know the outcome of our failures and to know that those are not great outcomes. They're things we want to avoid. So we begin to self-monitor and inflict that negative feeling or punishment that we
我们已经将这种感觉内化了。现在我们对失败产生了恐惧。我们阻止自己失败，因为我们有过足够多的经历，能够预料到如果我们失败了会发生什么。我们已经被条件反射般地知道了失败的结果，并且知道那些结果并不好。它们是我们想要避免的事情。所以我们开始自我监控，并将那种我们
normally receive from an external figure on ourselves. So these early learning experiences, I think, are why so few cultures and people have shifted to an attitude of almost psychological safety in which the rewards of learning from failure can be fully realized. And there's another key reason we avoid failure and it has to do with the perception of interpersonal or group shame. At the root of failure and a fear of failure is shame, which is a very unpleasant emotion associated with feeling like you're a bad person or are a flawed or defective individual.
通常从外部人物那里受到的负面感觉或惩罚施加在自己身上。所以这些早期的学习经验，我认为就是为什么很少有文化和个人转变为一种心理安全感态度的原因，在这种态度下，从失败中学习的好处才能得到充分实现。我们逃避失败还有另一个关键原因，这与对人际或群体羞耻感的感知有关。失败和对失败恐惧的根源是羞耻感，这是一种非常不愉快的体验，与觉得自己是个坏人、有缺陷或残缺的个体有关。
If I make a mistake, if I fail, how does that affect who I am and how I see myself, as well as how others see me? How will others see me is such a huge element of this anti-failia conundrum. And there's a very traditional and well-treaded idea in psychology that humans naturally seek the favor, acceptance, and admiration of the groups that they belong to. Maybe it's your friendship group, your family group, your religious group, your academic group. We want to be in the in group, basically. And one way that we stay liked by the group we're in is by sticking to the rules or blueprint on what behavior is accepted,
如果我犯了错误，如果我失败了，这会如何影响我是谁以及我如何看待自己，还有其他人如何看待我？其他人会怎么看我，这是这个反失败难题中一个巨大的要素。心理学中有一个非常传统且被广泛探讨的观点，即人类自然地寻求他们所属群体的青睐、接纳和赞赏。也许是你的朋友圈、你的家庭、你的宗教团体、你的学术团体。我们基本上都想加入圈子内。而保持被我们所在的群体喜爱的一种方法，就是坚持关于哪些行为被接受的规则或蓝图，
what actions and outcomes are accepted and which ones aren't. And if we stray, we may be outcast. And when we were primitive beings, that meant, you know, pretty much certain death if you weren't part of a tribe or a group. And that sense of fear, that fear reaction, it survives today in our limbic system. And that's a crucial part of the old brain that controls our behaviour to ensure survival, often unconsciously. And that's a big part of this.
哪些行动和结果被接受，哪些不被接受。如果我们偏离了，我们可能会被驱逐。当我们还是原始人时，这意味着，如果你不是部落或群体的一部分，基本上就意味着确凿的死亡。这种恐惧感，这种恐惧反应，在我们的边缘系统中延续至今。这是控制我们行为以确保生存的古老大脑的关键部分，通常是无意识的。这其中很大一部分是
It's unconscious. So let's give an example. Say you make like a really big mistake at work, been there, done that, got the T-shirt. You failed to kind of meet your boss's expectations for, I don't know, presentation or whatever, whatever you do for work. And the consequences of this will likely be criticism or some kind of critique that feels like rejection. And for a while, you might not feel like you are as respected or liked at work. you may not feel as accepted by the group. And that's where a big failure of failure comes from,
无意识的。让我们举个例子。假设你在工作中犯了一个非常大的错误，去过那里，做过那件事，也拿过纪念T恤。你未能达到老板对，我不知道，一个演讲或你在工作中做的任何事情的期望。这产生的后果很可能是批评或某种感觉像是拒绝的评判。有一段时间，你可能会觉得自己在工作中不像以前那样受人尊敬或喜爱了。你可能会觉得不那么被群体接纳。这就是对失败的巨大恐惧的来源，
the notion that you could be cast out from a group whose respect and favour you unconsciously need, you want, you crave. And the impact of failure is pretty magnificent on our self-concept and our confidence. Self-esteem or our self-concept, it's a self-evaluation construct that corresponds to an overall view
那种你可能会被一个你无意识中需要、想要、渴望其尊重和青睐的群体驱逐的想法。失败对我们的自我概念和自信心的影响是非常巨大的。自尊或我们的自我概念，它是一个自我评价结构，对应于我们对自己的内部思考和评估的总体看法，
of what we kind of contemplate and evaluate about ourselves, both internally, how we see ourselves and how we think others see us. Successes and failures, they're just inextricably linked to that, and they influence your mood, they influence your emotional states, all to varying degrees, as well as self-esteem levels, insofar that these events are perceived as personal successes or failures, which either contribute to the image you have or detract from it. Emotions and self-esteem, they're linked in everyday experience,
无论是在内部我们如何看待自己，还是我们认为别人如何看待我们。成功和失败与此密不可分，它们会在不同程度上影响你的情绪、你的情绪状态，以及自尊水平，只要这些事件被视为个人成功或失败，从而对你拥有的形象产生贡献或减损。情绪和自尊在日常经验中是联系在一起的，
such that people with high self-esteem report more positive states of emotion, and people who lack self-worth are generally in more of a negative mood. So when we fail, when a relationship breaks apart, when we lose a job or we miss out on an opportunity, this influences the characteristics and thoughts we assign to ourselves and can be really damaging for our self-esteem. And it can take a while to recover and receive the necessary reinforcement to rebuild those aspects of our identity that have been threatened by a failure. And I think importantly, but kind of like the modern 20-something person, social media also threatens to make
因此，高自尊的人表现出更多积极的情绪状态，而缺乏自我价值感的人通常处于更多的负面情绪中。所以当我们失败时，当一段感情破裂，当我们失业或错过一个机会时，这会影响我们赋予自己的特征和想法，并且对我们的自尊心造成真正的损害。恢复并获得必要的强化来重建那些因失败而受到威胁的身份认同方面，可能需要一段时间。而且我认为重要的是，就像现代二十多岁的人一样，社交媒体也威胁着要让
every slip-up an extinction level event socially and professionally. which contributes to this shame avoidance framework for our fear of failure that we kind of discussed before. Good news. When we get older, our failures don't seem to hurt our self-concept and the opinion or image we hold of ourselves as much. So in one study, researchers found that the impact that perceived failure has on our positive emotional states, it declines the older we are. I think older adults are assumed to change their affect states and reaction to positive and negative stimuli across the lifespan, but to less severe degrees. They also have more experiences and learning opportunities to now be able to appraise a potential failure for what it actually represents, which is something that isn't a really big deal. According to a lot of theoretical frameworks, older adults are just better equipped to regulate their emotional.
每一个失误在社交和职业上都变成毁灭级别的事件，这促成了我们之前讨论过的对失败恐惧的羞耻回避框架。好消息是。当我们变老时，我们的失败似乎对我们的自我概念以及我们对自己的看法或形象的损害没有那么大了。因此在一项研究中，研究人员发现，感知到的失败对我们积极情绪状态的影响会随着年龄的增长而减弱。我认为人们普遍认为成年人在整个生命周期中改变其情感状态以及对积极和消极刺激的反应，但程度没有那么剧烈。他们也有更多的经验和学习机会，现在能够将潜在的失败评估为它实际代表的东西，也就是一件并不是什么大不了的事情。根据许多理论框架，成年人在调节自己的情绪方面只是装备得更好，
states and to use this regulatory ability to manage positive and negative emotions that may affect how they see themselves, to kind of see them as something that yes, is related and yes, influences how they see themselves but isn't the be all and end all. So I guess that is something to look forward to. But in our 20s, there are certain people who can handle failure better than others. And I'm sure you've seen this amongst your friends, you know, the person who experiences a huge step back and it doesn't seem to bother them versus, I guess, people like myself, who it really does kind of get to. So this psychologist, Taya Cohen from Carnegie Mellon, I think, yeah, that's it. Carnegie Mellon makes the distinction between guilt-prone people and shame-prone people.
并且能够利用这种调节能力来管理可能影响他们如何看待自己的积极和消极情绪，将其视为确实相关且确实影响他们如何看待自己、但并非全部且不是生死攸关的事情。所以我想这是值得期待的。但在我们的二十多岁，有些人确实比其他人更能应对失败。我确信你在朋友中也见过这种情况，你知道的，那种经历重大挫折似乎对他们毫无影响的人，相比之下，我想，就像我自己这样，真的会往心里去。所以这位来自卡耐基梅隆大学的心理学家塔亚·科恩，我想，是的，就是这样。卡耐基梅隆大学区分了倾向于内疚的人和倾向于羞耻的人。
So bear with me here. When some people make mistakes, they tend to focus more narrowly on their behavior. You know, I made a mistake, I did a bad thing, and now I'm going to think of ways to correct for this, I'm going to improve. And that's an example of a guilt-prone person. They feel guilty for the mistake, but recognize it and use it as kind of motivation to change something outside of themselves and act in a way that they can avoid the problem in the future. and this psychologist Cohen says this type of person is different than the other group of shame prone people. So the shame prone person is kind of like this. If you do something wrong, you might think I'm a bad person rather than just I did a bad thing and I made a mistake.
所以请听我慢慢道来。当有些人犯错时，他们往往更狭隘地关注自己的行为。你知道，我犯了一个错误，我做了一件坏事，现在我要想办法纠正错误，我要改进。这就是一个倾向于内疚的人的例子。他们为这个错误感到内疚，但能认识到它，并将其用作改变自身以外的事物并采取行动以在未来避免这个问题的动力。
And if you think you're a bad person, that's much harder to counteract. And that might lead you to withdraw from people. So a healthier response to failure is focusing on, specific behaviours rather than looking at the experience as a reflection of yourself because you can easily change your behaviour but it's much harder to change who you are or who you think you are researchers have also found that people who strongly fear failure have a composite of two personality characteristics low achievement orientation that is they don't take much pleasure from accomplishment and meeting goals and high test anxiety, a fear of not performing well at a critical
这位心理学家科恩说，这类人与另一群倾向于羞耻的人不同。所以倾向于羞耻的人是这样的。如果你做错了什么，你可能会想“我是一个坏人”，而不是仅仅觉得“我做了一件坏事，我犯了一个错误”。如果你认为自己是个坏人，那就很难逆转了。这可能会导致你开始疏远人群。因此，应对失败更健康的反应是专注于具体的行为，而不是将这段经历视为对你自身的反映，因为你可以轻易改变你的行为，但要改变你是谁或你认为你是谁要困难得多。研究还发现，强烈害怕失败的人具有两种人格特质的组合：低成就导向，也就是他们从成就和实现目标中获得的快乐不多；高考试焦虑，也就是害怕在关键时刻表现不佳。
moment. So in other words, they're motivated less by the possibility of winning and gaining something of value, and they're more motivated by their anxiety about the possibility of messing up. And those are some of the same personality traits that drive perfectionism. And it can show up in people who are high achievers and people who are less motivated to achieve. Doesn't matter. In fact, perfectionism, I think, and fear of failure go hand in hand from a clinical perspective. There's one type of individual for whom failure is particularly hard to deal with and overcome. And if this is you, I'm so sorry. But maybe you'll listen to this kind of profile of this person and, you know, be able to be like, oh, it's not me. It's this condition. So Adelaophobia is a phobia.
换句话说，他们的动机较少来自获胜和获得有价值东西的可能性，而更多地来自他们对搞砸事情可能性的焦虑。这些也是驱动完美主义的同一些人格特质。它可以出现在高成就者身上，也可以出现在成就动机较低的人身上。这没关系。事实上，从临床角度来看，完美主义和对失败的恐惧是齐头并进的。有一类人对他们来说，失败是特别难以应对和克服的。如果这就是你，我感到非常抱歉。但也许你会听听对这类人的这种描述，你知道的，能够觉得，哦，这不是我，这是这种状况。阿得拉恐惧症是一种恐惧症。
or deep fear of failure which may lead people to avoid any situation where failure could take place, hence isolating themselves from new and novel experiences and opportunities. So Adelaphobia is often referred to as perfectionism, and whilst it is considered extreme perfectionism, this associate professor of psychiatry at the Will Cornel Medical College, his name is Dr. Gail Saltz, he says that it's more than that. It is a true irrational. And that's the key word when we think about phobia's irrational. Fear of making any form of mistakes.
或对失败的深度恐惧，这可能会导致人们逃避任何可能发生失败的情况，从而将自己与新的、新奇的体验和机会隔离开来。因此，阿得拉恐惧症通常被称为完美主义，虽然它被认为是一种极端的完美主义，但威尔康奈尔医学院的精神病学副教授，他的名字叫盖尔·萨尔茨博士，他说这不仅于此。这是一种真正的非理性。当我们在考虑恐惧症时，这是一个关键词——非理性。对犯下任何形式的错误感到恐惧。
As with any phobia, people with adelaophobia think about the fear of making a mistake in a way that means they have to avoid situations where there's a risk of that happening. And that's the other key feature of a phobia avoidance, so irrational and avoidance. And they also obsess a lot about. mistakes that they've made in the past or imagine mistakes they could make in the future. And these thoughts kind of cause them to have overwhelming anxiety, another aspect of a phobia. So it might make them feel panicky or nauseous, dizzy, or experience a rapid heartbeat. That kind of panic that sets in for a fear of failure, which is irrational.
与任何恐惧症一样，患有阿得拉恐惧症的人对犯错的恐惧的思考方式，意味着他们必须避开有这种风险发生的情况。这就是恐惧症的另一个关键特征——逃避，即非理性的逃避。他们还过度痴迷于过去犯下的错误，或者想象未来可能犯下的错误。这些想法往往会导致他们产生压倒性的焦虑，这也是恐惧症的另一个方面。所以这可能会让他们感到恐慌、恶心、头晕，或者经历心跳加速。那种因害怕失败而产生的恐慌感是非理性的。
And it often leads to constant judgment and a negative evaluation that you could never believe you're doing things the right way and it's a kind of perfectionism that's more than just striving for excellence or ambition you know we all innately wish to be successful however on some level the average person can anticipate accept and tolerate shortcomings we can tolerate mistakes and failed attempts but people with adela phobia they just feel crushed by even the idea of a failed attempt and it often makes them miserable and depressed and perhaps like, I don't know if this is part of the clinical definition, but definitely probably worse off because they aren't actually ever able to try new things and learn lessons from situations in which you're inevitably going to fail.
并且它经常导致持续的评判和负面评估，让你永远不相信自己正在用正确的方式做事，这是一种超越了追求卓越或雄心的完美主义，你知道的，我们所有人内心深处都希望成功。然而在某种程度上，普通人能够预料、接受和容忍缺点。我们可以容忍错误和失败的尝试，但患有阿得拉恐惧症的人即使一想到尝试失败就会感到被击碎。这常常让他们痛苦和沮丧，也许就像，我不知道这是否是临床定义的一部分，但肯定情况更糟糕，因为他们实际上永远无法尝试新事物并从那些不可避免会失败的情境中吸取教训。
I think an intense fear of failure is not a place we want to be in. And there's this saying, fail hard, fail soon and fail often. And I really love this saying, even if I struggle to fully realize it most of the time. We talked about this shift in mind frame earlier. But how is it that we can have a healthy relationship with failure such that it creates growth rather than shame? How can we be okay with failing often and not only be okay with it, but make it part of our life philosophy? Okay, I'm not going to give you a simple equation here. because I'm not a licensed psychologist.
我认为对失败的强烈恐惧不是我们想要停留的地方。有这样一句名言：狠狠地失败，尽早地失败，经常地失败。我真的很喜欢这句话，即使我大部分时间都很难完全做到这一点。我们之前讨论过这种心态的转变。但是我们怎样才能与失败建立一种健康的关系，使其产生成长而不是羞耻感呢？我们如何才能坦然接受经常失败，不仅能坦然接受，还能将其作为我们人生哲学的一部分呢？好吧，我不会在这里给你一个简单的公式。因为我不是执业心理学家。
I'm not a, I don't know, a life coach. Nor am I going to say, you know, our failure is avoidable if you just try a little harder. Like, we can get away with never failing. That's silly talk. That is so silly. Obviously, you're going to fail. Isn't that just, it's a part of life? You know, every parent has said that to you, I'm sure.
我不是，我不知道，也不是生活教练。我也不会说，你知道的，只要你再努力一点，失败是可以避免的。就像，我们可以做到永不失败一样。那是荒谬的说法。那是太荒谬了。显然你会失败。这难道不是，这只是生活的一部分吗？你知道，我相信每个父母都对你这么说过。
But I think it's important to talk about how our relationship with failure can change for the better. So there's a common clinical tool in psychology. It's called cognitive behavior therapy. For those who haven't heard about it, which I'm sure if you've ever been to a therapist, you have, but the gist is this. If you can change your perception of an event or an experience so that you would praise it as being positive or at the very least, not life-ruining, you allow yourself to behave in a manner that reflects that new mind frame.
但我认为讨论我们与失败的关系如何能朝着更好的方向转变是很重要的。在心理学中有一个常见的临床工具。它被称为认知行为疗法。对于那些没有听说过的人，我确信如果你去看过心理医生，你一定听说过，但其要点是这样的。如果你能改变你对某个事件或经历的看法，将其评估为积极的，或者至少不是毁灭生活的，你就会允许自己以反映那种新心态的方式行事。
So it's kind of like, I don't know, like a train. If you get the first part of the train moving, the second part follows. And we can apply this to failure. Choose a reasoning that works best for you. So maybe it's failure is nothing but an opportunity to grow or everyone fails. No one's paying attention to me in particular. Maybe it's, you know, with every failure, I'm one step closer to doing this right. Whatever justification you need, you get to choose it.
所以这有点像，我不知道，就像一列火车。如果你让火车的第一个部分动起来，第二个部分就会跟进。我们可以把这个应用到失败上。选择最适合你的推理。所以也许失败只不过是成长的机会，或者每个人都会失败。没有人特别在关注我。也许是，你知道的，每一次失败，我都离做对这件事更近了一步。无论你需要什么样的理由，你都可以选择它。
Find the thing that you can accept more than you can, you know, not accept failure and repeat that until you no longer feel threatened by the idea of screwing up or hurt by previous mistakes and failures that you've made. It's almost like an affirmation or it's like a soothing tool. Your cognition of a situation is linked to how you behave or react to that situation, as CBT says. Therefore, if you change your perception around failure, your acceptance of it as a part, of life and something important will follow suit. I think also importantly you need to detach the outcomes of your actions to your self-concept and that's something we talked about when we were referring to older people and how they're kind of more
找到那件你能接受、而不仅仅是无法接受失败的事情，然后重复这一过程，直到你不再受到搞砸事情的想法的威胁，也不再为以前犯下的错误和失败而感到受伤。这几乎就像是一种肯定，或者像是一种舒缓工具。正如认知行为疗法所说，你对某种情况的认知与你对该情况的行为或反应息息相关。因此，如果你改变对失败的看法，你对它作为生活一部分以及重要事情的接受度也会随之提高。我认为同样重要的是，你需要将行动的结果与你的自我概念解耦，这是我们在提到老年人以及他们对此更为
chill with it. Failure, it's linked to feelings and emotions like sadness, anxiety, stress, maybe even rage and those feelings are incredibly uncomfortable for any person and we will do anything to get rid of them. But they don't need to become deeply embedded truths about yourself. Those feelings and emotions will help you work harder to find different and better solutions in order for you to improve the next time. If you recognise that the consequences of your actions are just that, there are an outcome of a series of events and decisions,
从容时谈过的事情。失败，它与悲伤、焦虑、压力甚至愤怒等感觉和情绪联系在一起，对于任何人来说，这些感觉都极其令人不适，我们会不惜一切代价摆脱它们。但它们不需要成为关于你自己的深度内化真相。这些感觉和情绪将帮助你更加努力地寻找不同且更好的解决方案，以便你在下一次做得更好。如果你认识到行动的后果仅仅是后果，它们是一系列事件和决定的结果，
not just your self-concept. Sometimes there are things you can't control. You're not defective. because you've failed. There's always going to be new opportunities. There's going to be new things to strive for. So I think with much of psychology embracing that negative state while it's there, learning from it, not trying to avoid it, that can lead to healthy coping mechanisms rather than isolation, projection or suppression. It's not very growth mindset of you if you just suppress those negative feelings. And worst case scenario, it might lead to like a phoenix.
而不仅仅是你的自我概念。有时有些事情是你无法控制的。你并没有残缺。因为你失败了。总会有新的机会。总会有新的奋斗目标。所以我认为，在很大程度上，心理学拥抱这种存在时的负面状态，从中学习，而不是试图逃避它，这可以带来健康的应对机制，而不是孤立、投射或压抑。如果你只是压抑那些负面情绪，那可算不上什么成长型思维。最坏的情况下，它可能会导致一种凤凰
pattern of behaviour in which you don't even allow yourself to be in situations where you could make a mistake and then are you really fulfilling your potential? I don't know. Those are just some of my my more nuanced musings. I hope that despite the weird ramblings of this episode you've managed to take something in, learn something about the psychology. It's a bit of a shorter episode this week. I know. I'm sorry. I guess it's interesting. Like, failure, I've kind of been feeling that a lot recently, just with like making a big life decision, friendships ending, relationships ending, yeah, and just feeling pretty down on myself about how come I couldn't have anticipated the outcomes of some of my actions a little bit better.
涅槃式的行为模式，以至于你甚至不允许自己处于可能犯错的情境中，那么你真的在发挥你的潜力吗？我不知道。这些只是我的一些更为细致的沉思。我希望尽管这期节目有些古怪的闲聊，你还是成功吸收了一些内容，学到了一些关于心理学的知识。你知道，本周的节目有点短。我很抱歉。我想这很有趣。就像失败，我最近也有这种感觉，伴随着重大的生活决定、友谊的结束、感情的结束，是的，对于为什么我不能更好地预判我某些行动的结果，我感到非常沮丧。
But at the end of the day, I think this is just such a learning period in everyone's life. if you're around the same age as me, which I'm guessing you are if you're listening to this podcast. Yeah, I just think changing your mind frame is so important away from, you know, I failed, I failed, I failed to like, what did I learn here? And just some of those recent experiences, like, there's just been so many lessons that have come through. Despite, like, you know, not so much pain, but like the hurt of the experiences. So, yeah, just very excited to, like,
但归根结底，我认为这只是每个人人生中这样一个学习的阶段。如果你和我年龄相仿，我猜如果你在听这个播客的话，你大概也是。是的，我只是觉得改变心态非常重要，从“我失败了，我失败了，我失败了”转变成“我在这里学到了什么？”。并且正是最近的一些经历，带来了如此多的教训。尽管有，你知道，与其说是痛苦，不如说是经历带来的心痛。所以，是的，非常兴奋，
for the next chapter, I guess. But I think that's also silly. There's never chapters. It's just one big life. One big story. No chapters needed. Anyhow, sorry. Just using this as my personal journal.
迎接下一个章节，我想。但我也觉得这很荒谬。从来没有什么章节。这只是宏大人生的一部分。一个巨大的故事。不需要任何章节。总之，抱歉。只是把这当成我的个人日志。
I guess sometimes I find it that way because I know that I'll be the one probably listening back to this in 10 years. And it's good to kind of know where I was at. But I hope you did enjoy this episode. I hope you learned something. I hope if you have Adelophobia, you get some help because that shit sounds brutal.
我想有时我发现这样做是因为我知道我可能就是10年後回听这个节目的人。而且了解自己当时处于什么状态是很好的。但我希望你确实喜欢这一期节目。我希望你学到了一些东西。我希望如果你有阿得拉恐惧症，你能去寻求一些帮助，因为那玩意儿听起来太残酷了。
And thanks again for listening. Follow us on Instagram. Follow us on Facebook. I never use the Facebook page. But it's there. If that's your cup of tea, leave a review. I love when people leave me reviews.
再次感谢你的收听。在Instagram上关注我们。在Facebook上关注我们。我从来不用Facebook页面。但它就在那里。如果你喜欢那种风格，留个评论吧。我很喜欢大家给我留言。
I'll be sending you air kisses from afar if you do that. And I hope you have a magnificent week. I know uni started again. I know works back on. People are starting new jobs. It's all very exciting. So throughout all that, scared to fail and don't be scared to reach out and listen to the podcast. Wow, that was really smooth.
如果你这么做了，我会从远方给你送上飞吻。祝你拥有美好的一周。我知道大学开学了。我知道工作又恢复了。人们开始新的工作。这一切都非常令人兴奋。所以在这一切当中，不要害怕失败，也不要害怕伸出援手并收听这个播客。哇，转折得真顺畅。
Anyhow, I will see you guys soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side. a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
总之，我们回头见。2%。当旁边有自动扶梯时，只有这么一小部分人会选择走楼梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在这个光怪陆离的现代世界中培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“2%”。
On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。对于1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方收听Look Back At It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《学得艰难》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。这并不意味着你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要。
Listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHard radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听Learn the Hard Way。这是一个IHart播客。保证是由真人录制。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。